[Music]
the best way to make cooking easier and
less stressful on Christmas Day is to
get organized and prepare as much as
possible in advance leaving you more
time to spend with your family making a
stunning pork apricot and pistachio
stuffing the day before is a great way
to get ahead it's easy to do looks a
million dollars and tastes absolutely
delicious Christmas dinner for me is not
about food piled high on a plate less is
more
I'd rather have five or six things on a
play that taste absolutely delicious
then ten items tasting average stuffing
for instance I'd much rather put a lot
more effort into the stuffing and enjoy
it but eat a lot less of it first and
pork mince to the bowl season with salt
and pepper and mix take your grater
and a braver doubtful just get the
grater and grate the apple in there
usually stuffing is cooked in the turkey
but I'm doing mine separately so I can
make in advance and get the flavor and
presentation spot-on now the nice thing
about the Apple it goes pretty well with
the pork makes it a little bit sweeter
it also makes it a lot lighter as well
which is really important
next add a handful of chopped apricots
which gives the stuffing another fruity
note and a lovely texture the apple
disintegrates
but the apricots stay really nice intact
nice little bite then chop a handful of
pistachio nuts again I'm thinking on the
build up of textures flavor and also
color
pistachios in now give it a really good
mix grating some lemon zest the zest is
packed full of intensely flavored
essential oils which gives the stuffing
a vibrant citrus thing
[Music]
and for freshness at a handful of
coarsely chopped parsley the balance of
flavors is nice and delicate and it sits
beautifully with a turkey now sage and
pork and apple that's the perfect
marriage now I'm going to think about
the presentation skills Tim for a little
drizzle of olive oil and then we got a
real nice fragrant sage leaves the stage
leaves are used to wrap the stuffing
start by overlapping them
it's almost like rolling a cigar but
we're gonna roll it and sage leaves
taste is paramount but presentation is
really important to says we're spending
a few extra minutes to get this right
because it will make the final dish look
amazing now a little seasoned across the
top and then take your sausage mate I
don't want to do now let's put half it
onto the plate
[Music]
will you run your finger along with
stuffing this is where it takes on a
completely different flavor again I need
some spice in there I want a little bit
of heat in the stuffing so it's exciting
to eat no gays myrrh gays are
traditional North African sausages made
from beef or lamb and all gonna do now
they say the sausage and lay that in the
middle they're flavored with harissa a
fiery chili paste which gives them the
heat and distinctive color it really
does give that nice sort of wake-up call
inside the stuffing if you can't get
hold of myrrh gays other spicy sausages
likes fries Oh would work well too I'll
take the rest of stuffing and we'll sit
there on top so in cases and burgers
[Music]
what you go like that lifts up the Tim
fall very carefully and roll that over
let the temple do the work roll it nice
and tight there
fingers underneath just pull that back
the double check lovely look at it it's
not even cut yet and it looks delicious
the ultimate Christmas cracker fantastic
that sage will cook and really perfume
the sausage meat and you cut through the
center got a nice spicy sausage lovely
in now roll it across twist at the ends
and then from there up into the hands
and you push it in and twist and turn
all that's doing is just making the
perfect cylinder beautiful the stuffing
can be made wrapped and stored in the
fridge a day or two in advance that's
the first part of my ultimate Christmas
dinner ready on Christmas Day simply pop
it into the oven and cook at 200 degrees
for 40 minutes
[Music]
sources are one of the important ways
shifts an extra dimension and flavor to
dishes you can use this trick at home my
camera is cranberry and apple sauce is
another recipe I always cook a day in
advance it packs a wonderful punch that
really lifts the subtle flavor of the
turkey it's simple to make and with its
deep red vibrant color looks fantastic
on the plate the secret behind any good
Christmas is in the organization and
preparation anything you can get done in
advance do it apple and cranberry sauce
is a prime example first things first
we're gonna make a really nice caramel
sugar in at 150 grams of caster sugar to
a pan followed by a couple of star anis
that helps to really give a nice sort of
aniseed flavor to the cranberries next
lightly crushed ball cardamom pods this
has a lovely warm spicy sweet flavour
and wait for the sugar to melt and form
a caramel gritty important at the
conference now to color that caramel
still gets really nice and dark before
put the cranberries
[Music]
Wow smell of that Colonel is amazing
now cranberries in
members are very tart and acidic but
balanced with the sweetness of the
caramel and apples they give the sauce a
lovely dry sharp note to tell if they're
fresh drop them on a hard service the
higher they bounce the fresher they are
the secret now is for a caramel to
blister the cranberries and really start
to break that down smells fantastic next
core peel and thinly sliced two apples
unless the sauce is finished it really
just helps to sort of wake up the flavor
of the turkey now the cranberries are
starting to break down Apple in smells
fantastic a touch of salt and pepper
that's really important really helps to
balance that tartness against the
acidity of the apple song pepper really
brings it back the smell is fantastic so
I sort of sweet sour spicy nice now from
there
deglaze the pan with touch a port around
the side deglazing dissolves all the
lovely sticky can eyes bits of food that
are stuck to the pan and incorporates
them into the sauce
next add the zest of an orange
and for another layer of fragrant
sweetness squeezing the juice lovely
then cook on a low heat for five to ten
minutes to thicken but remember the
source will become even thicker once
it's cooled down now that is the right
texture I don't want a runny sauce on
something really nice and thick
delicious packed full of flavor perfect
if you really want to get ahead
this sauce can be made three or four
days in advance and kept in the fridge
which allows the flavors to develop even
more
[Music]
then on Christmas Day
simply bring it up to room temperature
and serve another job done leaving you
more time to enjoy this very special day
[Music]
another golden rule of Christmas is
don't do all the work yourself delegate
at home I'm raising my own little
brigade of sous chefs who always willing
to help with any recipe that involves
chocolate and the possibility of licking
the mixing spoon
another thing I always do the day before
Christmas is knock up a batch of mint
chocolate truffles there child's play to
make and have a wonderful fresh mint
flavor the perfect after-dinner
chocolates right Megan Jack I need some
help yeah
chocolates mint truffles first things
first you want me to do just get this
block of dark chocolate and just break
up into small pieces
okay make this for you thank goodness
for you mate where'd you get that tie
from anti-fur base smart right
mint chocolate truffles the secret here
is getting that mint flavor into the
chocolate so low missing do get a little
bunch of mint and just lightly bruise it
you can flavor the truffles with
whatever takes your fancy from fresh
chili which gives it a surprisingly
delicious kick to orange zest to a
splash of brandy right double cream and
single cream in
[Music]
the cream makes the truffles wonderfully
soft luscious and rich next add a
generous pour of honey which helps to
sweeten the dark chocolate
now bring now to the boil another secret
is we pour that on top of the chocolate
okay so we literally got two minutes to
get this done quick that's why I need
some help yes can you beat this shot
with a rolling pin that's a very good
idea or would it be to school no it was
a very good idea because what we can't
afford to do is for the Queen to reduce
of the cream reduces then the
consistency of the truffle becomes too
hard that's a very good idea jack you
know now gently with that then what your
big sis has got more than one boyfriend
Jack what's her name Emma what you
bought Emma for Christmas don't tell me
Dad
yeah a table to daddy's restaurant next
at 130 grams of softened butter and to
give the troubles of glorious richness
and Sheen bring over the smaller base
yeah nice good once the cream of milk
have come to the boil really smell the
mint strain over the broken chocolate
that smells delicious and push that mint
flavor through there so every does come
out yeah so we just come out see how the
chocolates dissolving and that honey has
given a really nice glaze sweetness as
well because it's bitter chocolate
that's right dark chocolate and then the
butter starts to give the chocolate a
really nice shine so then what will
actually happen it do that look at that
peaceful right that will hit the spoon
Spri tongue out right then pour the
chocolate into a container and chill in
the fridge for about an hour to firm up
Jack I don't want your fingers in there
let it get nice and firm as the truffle
mixture sense prepare the coating so
have one for the adults in cocoa powder
yes and one with flight yes no surprise
surprise
so wait for you hands down so look we
just go like that and twist the flake on
to the plate you can coat the truffles
and anything you like finely chopped
pistachios or almonds work really well
with the mint or to give them a bit of
crunch plain brown sugar
[Music]
once the truffle mixture is set it's
time to roll out the chocolates make out
oh dear right okay I'm going to show you
one first yes sir hands really nicely
cold now the secret is in there Wow
manipulate it first like that and then
look roll and then quickly bang look
nothing all my hands shake off excess
and then just beautiful now in there
let's go call Jack dear hello when you
ready be newsy by the time we get one
done
it's trying time drop on there rather
place on there making
and I think about making them by hand
then all the exact same size yeah
handmade chocolate mint truffles Jack
the secret is a truffle is a one-bite
wonder not a golf ball have you hurry up
because of the ganache starts melting
we're in trouble
I thought you said there wasn't giving
me any chocolate on your hand cuz you're
slow show me hands Oh jet let me help
you here yeah not so not so big round
like that like that
yep and then like that and straight in
time for your Zico cover this time quick
and whilst he's gone let's turn these
into pop a little shoulders when the
truffles are coated and the kids are
cleaned up decorate them with sprigs of
mint so looks nice and we don't try one
oh yeah please okay which wants to go
full sake or cocoa flake really taste
the mint debris Testament canon
then prise the truffles away from the
kids and pop in the fridge ready for
Christmas Day another job done
[Music]